Hello and welcome to
Central Nervous System
Infections, Viruses
1 and 2, and this is
part of several
lectures that involve
central nervous system
infections, it includes
also bacteria and
parasites and fungi.
Here are the learning
objectives for these
two lectures, basically
we're going to
talk about different
types of viral central
nervous system infections
and what causes
them, we're going
to also compare and
contrast bacterial and
viral meningitis, and
we've already done
that in the bacterial
central nervous system
infection, so this is
going to be a review
for you. We're also
going to compare the
properties of most
common viral ideologies
of meningitis, identify
and talk about the
importance of CSF
analysis, and the
epidemiology, which plays
a very important role
in viral ideology.
Here's the outline
of the lecture.
Initially we'll just
review basically the
terminology of
central nervous system
infections and then
we'll talk about how they
occur. That's kind
of a review from the
bacterial one and then
we'll talk about how
central nervous system
infections are, how
the tissues are damaged
by viruses and then
we'll We'll compare
and contrast bacterial
and viral meningitis,
and then talk about
specifically acute
viral meningitis and the
common causes of that,
and the different
epidemiologies that are
related to that. Then we'll
also do the same for
viral encephalitis.
We discussed in the
bacterial central
nervous system infection
PowerPoint how, you
know, the definition
of meninges and a
little bit different
between acute and chronic,
and we talked about
viral fungal and
what the term excepting
mean and we also
talked about encephalitis
which is actually
information of the
brain tissue or the
brachium itself. We
talked about brain
abscesses and myelitis.
In regards to viruses,
viruses mainly cause
acute meningitis and
encephalitis and some
can cause myelitis
like polio but that's
becoming more rare
so we probably won't
discussed it as much,
so our focus is going
to be mainly acute
viral meningitis and
viral encephalitis.
The most common way
by which microbes
enter the central
nervous system is
through the hematogenous
drought by blood.
And you know of
course there's a blood
brain barrier which
prevents a lot
of these organisms
from actually getting
there. So only few
are able to, the
majority can't,
but they'll find
different ways. It
could be through the
acquiring for the
respiratory epithelium,
like aerosol,
droplet, for example.
That's how meningocloxide,
the bacterium,
nice here how
meningocloxides
does it. Or the organism
can be introduced
into the blood by
an animal bite,
like in the case
of rabies virus,
or bug bite,
mosquito, like West
Nile and other type
of arboviruses.
And sometimes it
could be transpacently
from the mom, for
example, cytomegalo,
repella or Zika virus
use that route and
then they go from the
blood to the central
nervous system via
the choroid plexus.
Occasionally but
not often sometimes
the microorganisms can
get to the meninges
and other parts of
the central nervous
system directly
through the like the
like from the sinuses
if there's some
cracks or there's
some anatomical
structures or
fractures that can
actually allow the
organs in direct
access, but that's
not typical.
You can also have
direct narcoleasure,
like if somebody has
trauma or surgery,
they can of course,
you know, like
neurosurgery or
spinal cord or brain
surgery, they
can introduce
organisms or, you
know, blunt objects.
For viruses to infect
central nervous
system, they have
to display tropism
for the central
nervous system, or
tissue tropism, or
neutropism specifically
for the central
nervous system,
so binding to specific
receptors which
allow access.
Here are a few examples,
like poliovirus,
for example, has
neutropism, or sorry,
tropism for motor
neurons, neurotropism,
both the spinal cord
medulla, MoBs virus
binds specifically to
ependimal cells, ependimal
cells usually align
the ventricles in like
fetal brains and
ependimal cells have cilia
which actually, both
the cerebral spinal
fluid, rabies virus can
enter like the distal
terminals of peripheral
nerves and then go
by exoplasmic transport
to each nerve like
into the sensory ganglia
and the spinal cord
and another one can
actually go through the
olfactory nerve endings
and so like we have
nasal infection can
occur with like rabies
and arbovirus and they're
not typical but if
there's a high airborne
concentration of
the virus for example
you enter into a cave
filled with a lot of
ads and you have so much
then you actually
overwhelm the upper
respiratory tract and
then the virus can enter
through that. But
that's not a very common
method of reaching the
central nervous system.
Other examples can take
place, for example,
after a virus,
especially with latent
viruses, where you
can have the primary
infection, for example,
with varicose zoster,
you get chicken pox
when you're a child
and then the virus
spreads to the skin
through sensory nerves
and become latent in
the neurons of the sensory
ganglia. Reactivation
can happen or not
happen but in a
small number of people
reactivation results
and spread the virus
again through sensory
nerves to produce
what's called jingles.
We don't know
why some people
get jingles and
others don't,
so it's still
hard to pin down.
It must have to do
with their body,
genetic makeup,
immune system.
****** simplex virus,
same way, spreads to
nerves like you get
your primary infection,
you know, whether
it's the oropharyngeal
infection,
that's itch, the
****** simplex
virus 1, or *******
because that's ******
simplex virus 2.
Either way,
HSV1 infects the
trigeminal nerve and HSV2
will affect the sacral
ganglia. Then the virus
becomes latent in the
sensory neurons and
then after a while
becomes activated for
different reasons.
Again sometimes
immunosuppression
as a result of like
another infection
or some you know
type of situation or
environment and becomes
reactivated and then the
virus spreads again
down the sensory nerves
into the mucosal
surfaces and comes out in
these vesicles filled
lesions and so of course
in the case of HSV1
that's a cold sore or
in the case of HSV2
that's ****** genitalis
and either way those
are the mechanisms for
the virus to spread
to other individuals.
Let's talk a little
bit next few slides
about the epidemiology
of viral central nervous
system infection.
How does that affect
the frequency and where
disease happen and
how common? So of course
there are seasonal
variations for
viruses. For example,
arboviruses typically
spread by vectors
so you need like
mainly mosquitoes and
sometimes ticks and
of course those are
more common in
summer so you expect
that to be more
frequent in the summer.
Other type of viruses
like entodoviruses
usually peak in late
summer, early fall.
Others are just
sporadic. They
don't have any
specific variation.
****** simplex varax
is an example of
that. It caused the
most common type of
sporadic violence
virus in adults and
that is not
associated with season
or associated with
a particular like
field trip or being
outside or going
to a cave or
anything like that.
Many of the Argo
viruses pick up their
names. A lot of viruses
pick up their names
from where they were
isolated. And of
course California and
the Satellitis virus,
because it was first
in California, St.
Louis, because it's
St. Louis, Missouri,
West Nile, because the
Nile Delta in Uganda,
Zika virus, same. And
so, but the important
thing to remember
is that although
these viruses have
certain locations named
after them, they're
not confined to these
locations and they're
not endemic only
there. Many of those
now are spread worldwide
and so they have
a much more larger
distribution than
what the name entails.
You know for example
Zika usually was
named for a forest
in Uganda but
now it's common in
South and Central
America and throughout
the Caribbean.
So, West Nile virus, same
thing. First,
I was in the
Nile Delta in Uganda
too, but now it's pretty
much distributed
worldwide and we've got
several cases a
year, the cases of
West Nile virus
in North America
nowadays. So,
again, many things
are attributed
to this, probably
some of it is
climate change,
international travel,
etc., shipping.
This is a great table
for you to review,
to be able to review,
for example, the common
viruses that cause
both encephalitis and
acute meningitis. So,
and it describes them
for virus type,
whether it's DNA or RNA
virus, and if whether
there's a specific
geographic location
or not, or widely
distributed, so that's
kind of important, and age
group, what is the
major age? Everybody,
more adults, older
adults, or young
children, for example,
eastern equine
encephalitis is more
common in children.
And then season,
for example, ******
simplex 1 and 2
have no seasonal.
On the other hand,
West Nile, St. Louis
encephalitis is
more of the summer,
as you expect when
there's mosquitoes.
Okay,
rabies virus
all year round,
very shallow
zoster more winter,
because it's pressed
by a droplet and when
people are closer
together in the
cold. And then
there's the last size
here, basically the
last column talks
about notable
features, for example,
that can help you
distinguish some
of these key viral
ideologies. So
please review these
this table and it
can help you sort
out your information
better in a more
concise manner.
This slide shows the
most common viral
ideologies of central
nervous system infections
with the leading ones
being enteroviruses.
We'll talk a little
bit about enteroviruses
more specifically and
why they mailed that
way, but basically
like Coxsackievirus, A
and B, Echovirus and
enterovirus are all
leading causes of viral
CNS infections, followed
by Arboviruses,
which pretty much are
predominantly viruses
that cause encephalitis,
and that includes
eastern western equine,
encephalitis virus, La
Crosse, and San Luis.
After that comes next
is ****** simplex
virus and then
varicella zoster.
There are less common
viral agents called
CNF infection. It's
good to know those and
we'll mention a couple
of them but we won't
discuss every single
one of them. One of
them is JC virus
which actually causes
progressive multifocal
locoencephalopathy or
for short PML and we'll
discuss that a little
bit more, rabies virus,
lymphocytic cordial
meningitis virus,
LCMV, poliovirus,
which usually used to
be the major cause of
infantile paralysis,
and because of the
vaccine, as you can see
in the figure on the
right side, right
here, it is very, the
introduction of the vaccine
made a huge difference
in the incidence as
well as the death
related to polio vaccine.
The polio vaccine
was made around the
1955s. There were two
different variants
and you can see how
there was a killed one
in 1955 and then a live
one was introduced in
the early 1960s and
as a result the
incidence of polio have
decreased significantly.
Thankfully, it used
to be on the World
Health Organization's
next disease
to eradicate.
Secretary IgA, from
an immunological
standpoint, seems to
be a very important
part for patients
to develop in order
to fend off from a
lot of these viral
central nervous system
infections, because
it can block the
virus from entering,
But predominantly
through our mucous
membranes, whether
that may be GI tract
or that could be the
respiratory tract.
Viruses are
considered the leading
cause of a category
called aseptic
meningitis. And
basically that means that
it's a type of
meningitis where
cultures are negative
and it's not going
something like a
bacteria or ******.
What does that mean
it's automatically
viruses? it could
also be parasites
or something that
does not typically
grow. So it's not
by default a viral
meningitis, but viruses
cause the majority
of what we call
aseptic meningitis.
And, you know,
symptoms are very
similar to what you
see with bacterial
meningitis. You've
got the fever,
rash maybe more
evident here than with
bacterial meningitis.
Everything else almost
looks the same.
headache, local agility,
photophobia, and of
course one of the unique
things is the
increased number of
lymphocytes, lymphocytic
pleiocytosis, which you
do not see in acute
bacterial meningitis.
This slide is the
same one we had in the
bacterial central
nervous system infection
where we're contrasting
bacteria and virus
meningitis. So this
is kind of a review,
but it's good to
remember this and
remember this topic is
very high yield and so
more usually have
several questions about
this subject so knowing
you know how the
disease presents
uh csf analysis the
difference between protein
levels glucose levels
lymphocytes um you
know it's very crucial
in the in distinguishing
whether you
have viral or bacterium
and of course here
we look at outcomes
mortality versus low
and the importance
of treatment
especially in the
case of bacterial.
One thing to note
here too is that in
infants we always start
empirical antimicrobial
therapy even if
viral is suspected.
The reason for that
is infants don't
have a very good immune
system and so usually
the CSF analysis may
not be or may not
look like we expected
to because there's
no reaction from
the immune response.
This slide is
also the view
showing the
normal values of
glucocides and whether
we're looking at for
example during acute
bacterial meningitis
versus for example
chronic micro bacterial
pungal versus acute
viral meningitis versus
encephalitis or even if
it's a brain abscess.
This is laboratory
analyses would come
on exam questions and
of course on boards
and those are
important for of course
diagnosis and
making sure that the
patients are treated
properly because all
of these are usually
life-threatening
illnesses.
Again we can't emphasize
enough that the
CSF analysis is very
important for diagnosis
of these diseases and
vital acute meningitis
anencephalitis
lymphocytic pleocytosis
tends to be the most
common observation.
Protein levels can
be either normal
or slightly
elevated, so don't be
surprised if they're
slightly elevated.
Glucose is normal, unlike
in bacteria, it's low.
And typical
opening pressure
could be either
normal or mild.
And a lot of times the
complete blood count
will kind of look very
similar to the CSF
findings and
sometimes can involve
increasing in monocytes
and again you expect
that there's no
culture you want to
have any organisms
like stain the grub
stain and so or the
oramine, rhodamine which
identifies phycobacteria
or for example
india-inc preparations
which is for
cryptococcus and cultures
come back negative
for bacteria and fungi
and all this together
will obviously eliminate
bacteria, fungi,
and leads to
viruses being the
proper presumptive
diagnosis. To
confirm, probably
most likely,
especially recently,
nucleic acid amplification
is the way to go.
It's very specific,
very sensitive, sometimes
it's almost 100%,
and basically we're
talking here about PCR,
like RT-PCR, for
example, letters used for
the interovirus kit
and sometimes those
can involve multiple
strains so they can
actually so it's a
multiplex type of PCR
where you can fish out
more than one strain
and they're very rapid
so you can get the
results almost in one
day and in a disease
like this when
you're racing against
time that becomes
extremely important. Just
briefly, encephalitis
is typically
caused by viruses. A
lot of them are the
autoviruses and
sometimes it can be also
associated with
meningitis where you
start with meningitis
and end up with
encephalitis, so
that's not uncommon.
So it can happen
sporadically
and that's typically
very common
with ******
simplex virus and
to a lesser extent
ferracella zoster and
much more less commonly
with endoviruses.
There are a lot of
epidemics that can take
place often with other
viruses, usually,
and of course we have
alpha viruses like
the eastern equine and
the western equine.
We have the falaviviruses
like the West
Nile virus in St.
Louis, and bunia viruses
such as california
encephalitis and
lacrosse virus, and
we'll talk about those.
CSF for analysis
for vital acetylitis
looks very similar
to acute meningitis
and usually is
also confirmed by
nucleic acid
amplification like PCR.
Imaging might look
a little different
with of course
involvement of
the brain brain
chemo but otherwise
it doesn't look
that different.
The next few
slides and the rest
of this lecture
we're going to
talk about
ideologies of vital
central nervous
infection and we're going
to start with the
intro viruses which is
quite a large group into
viruses from the name.
They basically multiply
and enter in the
GI tract. They don't
cause disease in the
GI tract, but that's
their point of entry.
They're the most common
cause of acute viral
meningitis, and they
are typically small,
non-enveloped, positive
single-striented
RNA viruses with an
icosahedral capsid. And
they are lytic, not
lysogenic. They belong
to the family called
Piconaviridae and that
basically stands for
pico which is small
pico-RNA because they
have very small RNA
genomes. That's where
the name comes from.
There are multiple
serotypes as you can see
right here. There are
three types of poliovirus.
The poliovirus
belongs to this group.
Coxsackievirus
24 serotypes of
Coxsackievirus,
6-0 types of XIQB,
34-0 types of
ECHO, and then
there's intervirus 4.
And all these are major
causes of viral
meningitis.
As expected, because
they are interviruses
and enter through
the gut, they're
transmitted predominantly
by the ***** or
rot, usually food,
contaminated water,
and people don't wash
their hands well.
of course they
replicate in the GI
tract and spread
through the bloodstream
causing viremia and
then reach other organs
like the meninges.
The viruses are very
stable, can survive
even in chlorinated
swimming pools and
the GI tract with all
the acid and everything
and sewer systems
and that's why they
can persist in the
environment and continue
to cause infections.
Coxsackie
viruses typically
cause a lot of
vesicular diseases
like foot and
mouth disease
which is highly
infectious or herpengina.
They can also cause
some pericarditis and
other forms of diseases,
but they're also
one of the causes of
acute viral meningitis,
and that's why we
mentioned them here.
The term actually
Coxsackie comes
from the town
actually called
Coxsackie, which
was first isolated.
It's a little south
of New York, so
here's like Albany,
as you can see. It
doesn't mean it's
restricted in that area,
but that's where it
was first isolated.
Diagnosis like all
the rest you know with
the nucleic acid
amplification pretty much
PCR and the disease
is usually self
-limiting the viral
meningitis unless you end
up with encephalitis
or meningitis in that
case and that typically
becomes a little
bit more difficult
or life-threatening
and requires more
intervention and that
usually happens in
children that are more one
year or younger and
maybe that's because
they don't have a
mature immune system.
As we discussed
in addition to
enteroviruses,
arboviruses are key
in forming a lot
of encephalitis.
These are mostly
vector-born illnesses
and usually the
vector is mosquitoes
and they can infect
a variety of mammals
and so a lot of
those mammals tend
to be also the
reservoir, whether it's
you know like small
rodents or fowl,
birds, horses, etc
and you know the major
ones belong to
the alpha viruses,
libiviruses, and pneumonia
and there's the list
here from Eastern
equine, Western
equine encephalitis,
St. Louis, West Nile,
Japanese encephalitis
virus, and lacrosse.
A lot of people and
I think I would say
the majority if ever
get affected by these
organisms will have
absolutely no symptoms.
They could be
asymptomatic and only
a few and we don't why
develop serious life
-threatening illnesses
and there doesn't
seem to be anything
in between so to
speak but that's
sometimes how microbes go.
Eastern equine
virus causes eastern
equine encephalitis
and of course it's
transmitted by from
humans and horses
injured by a bite
of an affected
mosquito incubation
period varies between
four to ten days
symptoms typically
sudden onset of
fever, muscle pain
and headache of
increased severity.
A third of people with
clinical encephalitis
end up dying from the
disease, so it's a
really, pretty high
mortality rate, and seems
to be endemic in the
New England states.
is western equine
encephalitis. It's an
important cause of the
lives of both horses
and humans in North
America, mainly western
parts of the United
States and also Canada.
The life cycle involves
birds, which
is infection.
It doesn't seem
to, you know, they
don't show any
symptoms so they end up
being more of the
reservoir of the
infection. And of course
mosquitoes, I mean
mosquitoes are not
affected either.
Very similar
symptoms like we'd
expect, you know,
sudden fever,
headache, nausea,
maybe vomiting,
can be anorexia, and
malaise as a result
of both nausea
and vomiting. When
there's an altered
mental status weakness
and sometimes there
might be signs of
meningeal irritations
or involvement of
meninges beyond the
brain parenchyma.
Next we're going to
discuss St. Louis
encephalitis virus which
is the leading cause
of epidemic Flavivirus
encephalitis in the
United States, San Luis
Encephalitis is the
most common mosquito
-transparent human
pattern in the U.S.
It's pretty widespread,
it's distributed
throughout all the 48
continental states, you
know there's not a lot
of cases since 1964,
there's only been 5,000
average couple hundred
cases a year um so
not terrible um
illness can be you know
from just headache uh or
to very severe managers
fly with both involvement
of the managers
and the parenchyma
and a pretty high
case fatality ratio of
five to fifteen percent
again that's super
high if you can think
about corona and corona
had a 0.1 percent
fatality just
for comparison
As we talked
about before, West
Nile Virus was
isolated in the
West Nile Delta
in Uganda in 1937.
The first outbreak
that happened
in New York
City, mostly in
the Queens, took
place in 1999.
So if you look at the,
you know, from the
first discovery
of the virus,
1937, to the first
time it actually
came all the way
to New York, it
was a lot of years.
Obviously, climate
change and probably
national travel both
played a role in
introducing this
pathogen into the US.
Mostly the
vector is here,
the mosquito that
actually transmits it.
That's kind of the
key thing. Once you
have that, all you
need is few cases and
then you end up having
more of the virus.
Birds are reservoirs.
You know other
animals are
just accidental
or incidental.
So are humans.
I don't think
it's really
meant for humans,
but some people, a
few people get it.
Next we're going
to talk about is
La Crosse encephalitis
virus, which
was first discovered
in the town
of La Crosse,
Wisconsin in 1963.
The virus has of
course been identified
as several
Midwestern and Mid
-Atlantic states,
so just never stays
confined obviously
to that town.
Usually about 75
cases of this virus,
of cephalitis caused
by this virus,
are going to
report each year
to the CDC, so not a lot.
And most of them occur
in people under 16
years of age, so immunity
must play a role.
And the life cycle of
the virus is between
mosquitoes and a lot of
animals like chipmunks,
squirrels, etc. and
they maintain the
virus in these forests,
and those habitats.
Next we'll talk about
this ****** simplex 1
and 2. These are of
course similar viruses,
but they don't have
identical ********.
They're extremely similar.
They are enveloped
double-stranded DNA
viruses. They have an
icosahedral capsid. They
are obviously latent
viruses, so they can,
you know, become a
provirus and and put
their genome in the host
DNA and lay dormant
for years and years.
Some of the common
vital cytopathic
effects that are
associated with ****** is
and these are
important for diagnosis
from a pathological
standpoint is what's
referred to as Calgary
type A internuclear
inclusions and from
the figure here
it kind of shows it
so this is a typical
cell, what the nucleus
looks like, and
this is what inclusions
or counter-type
intranuclear inclusions
look like. But
basically there's a
halo that builds up
around the nuclei,
and you can see some
of them here too on
this actual histological
slide, and a much
much better close
-up right there. And
so these are usually
suggestive of ******
simplex disease.
Also one other thing
that's seen is the
presence of giant multi
-nucleated cells and
that's because of
cystic deformation from
this virus and those
are best seen on
a zonk smear usually
using a GIMSA stain.
Viruses are also similar
except for the it
shows the effects so
while ****** simplex 1
causes cold sores in
the mouth ****** simplex
2 mainly causes
******* lesions. And so
they both infect a
variety of epithelial
cells, typically at
the site of entry, and
they cause these raised
fluid film vesicles.
And as we talked about,
zonk smear usually
helps very well in
identification with
those. And zonk
smear basically is
a stained smear of
like scrapings or
scabs of the base
of the lesion, and
you've got GIMSA.
Confirming the etiology
of these viruses
is again like most
of them is by PCR.
Serology is not
useful because most
of the population
already have
****** and so everybody
will be positive
so it doesn't
tell you anything.
Classic way by which
****** virus is infected
basically after the
main infection or
the primary infection
or whether it's around
the mouth or ********.
This virus infects
the neurons and intervenes
in the epithelial
location when they
travel retrograde
into the ganglia where
they establish a late
infection. Typically
it's a trigeminal
ganglia for oral ******
and the sacral ganglia
for the ******* ******.
Both can reactivate
in the ganglia,
replicate and travel
down back and show up
as either cold sores
or ******* sores and
usually those vesicles
are infectious that's
kind of how the
virus spreads from one
person to the other.
Most HSV encephalitis
are usually caused by
****** simplex one so
pretty much both adults
and children you know
after they're born.
HSV-1 as we talked a
little before is the
most common viral
cause of sporadic viral
encephalitis you know
there's no season
to it there's no
specific epidemiology.
Again, reactivation
can spread the skin,
branches of the
trigeminal nerve,
you know, as we
talked about causing
sores on the
lips, or even the
brain and affecting
the meninges.
Most, there's some
symptoms include
bizarre behaviors
displayed by
patients, personality
changes, insomnia,
and even gustatory
hallucinations.
Now,
neonatal ******
simplex infection. The
majority of those
are actually caused
by ****** simplex
virus 2, which
is typically acquired
during the vaginal
delivery if the
mom has HSV-2 and
contact with secretions
during birth.
Untreated neonatal
HSV-2 infection can
actually disseminate
to central nervous
system in most cases,
so it really has
to be treated, mom
has to be tested.
Antiviral therapy
typically is ciclovir
which is a base
analog and or any
derivatives like
biceclovir, peniclovir,
and famiciclovir and
that treatment is
essential and has
very good outcomes.
The next is talking
about varicella
zoster virus and
this is obviously
the virus that
causes chickenpox and
of course later
manifests itself as
zoster or shingles
when reactivated.
Chickenpox is simply
acquired by any
lesion, but you can
also get it from
contacting the
affected skin vesicles.
The virus usually
replicates respiratory
tract, but then goes
to the bloodstream
and to the skin,
showing these
characteristic pox,
smallpox lesions that
are shown. Sorry,
I mean lesions that
are small. I don't
want to call it
smallpox because
this is not smallpox,
and this is chickenpox.
But the name of
course came from
smallpox because the
lesions are similar,
except just smaller.
The virus then goes
from the skin to
the sensory nerves
and becomes latent in
just similar to
****** in the nerve
cell bodies like
the dorsal root or
cranial nerve ganglia.
Again very latent
virus, the DNA virus,
the reactivation,
the neurotropism,
all very similar.
Thankfully there are
of course vaccines
for the original
disease chickenpox but
there's also vaccines
now for the shingles.
The Zostavax is
usually recommended for
people of 60 and then
the Shingrix which is
a more recent vaccine.
The Zostavax was in
2006 so it's an over
15 year old and the
Shingrix vaccine is
more recent maybe year
2000 and that's
recommended to over 50
years and that helps
with preventing shingles
and usually people
get shingles and we
don't know why some
do and some don't they
even after they recover
they develop like
constantly skin rash
and constant irritation
they reach it could
be quite a nuisance
let's talk a little
bit about jc virus the
cause of agent of
progressive multifocal
leukoencephalopathy
or pml this is a
human polioma virus it's
not enveloped double
strand DNA and again
chycosidrocapsis.
There's a lot of
similarities. It usually
enters the respiratory
tract and then
spreads to kidneys. It
does infect and causes
latency in both B
cells and monocytes.
Reactivation then
only occurs in
immunocompromised
patients, for example
somebody with
HIV or AIDS, and
then spreads to
the central nervous
system and cause
what's called PEML.
PEML is a subacute
demyelinating disease
and necrotic, so
there's actual death,
both loss of
myelin and death of
tissue of neurons in
the central nervous
system, and the
disease can progress
to result in paralysis
and even death.
Approximately 10% of
people with AIDS would
develop, so obviously
they have AIDS, that
means they're not
sticking to our therapy,
which is enteroviral
therapy, and so they
went went all the
way and developed
AIDS. 10% of these
people develop PML which
is 85 of all cases
of PML and that has
really a 90% mortality
rate. So it's very
important to stick
with ART therapy and
maintain that and
of course these
incidences have
decreased significantly
with ART therapy
and if people
are sticking with
that therapy.
Diagnosis again,
PCR to detect
the viral genome
index into a CSF
sample and also
combine that with
imaging CT or MRI.
Rabies virus,
it belongs to
the family rhabdoviridae.
One of the key
features about it
is it looks like
bullet shaped as
you can see right
here. This is the
caps, it looks
like bullet shaped.
It's enveloped. It's
a negative sense, a
single-stranded RNA
virus. It usually can
cause acute encephalitis
in just about
all warm-budded hosts,
humans and so on.
And of course,
it's a zoonosis, so
humans are
accidental hosts, but
it's quite common
in all animals.
Again, most of them
are susceptible and
even though they are
only certain species
mainly raccoons and
bats tend to be the
main reservoir for the
disease. So controlling
the populations of
these animals is
important in controlling
this disease. Usually
people are transmitted
through a bite
of an animal that's
actually infected. That
could be a bat or
raccoon, bat or bat
or a bat of a dog and
then after that you
have uptake into
peripheral nerves and then
virus goes to the
center of the system.
it's very similar
retrograde exoplasmic
flow and during
the period once the
cerebrum and the brain
is infected you end
up with that classic
behavior changes
associated with rabies
you know things like
photophobia and some
of those bizarre
symptoms that we see
in this infection.
One of the key
features of detecting
rabies virus
is looking for
the cytopathic effects
called Negri bodies.
Negri bodies, which
are pretty much
cytoplasmic eosinophilic
inclusion bodies
in neuronal cells. And
you can see them right
here under the arrow
and right here. So,
you know, it looks
like close to
pyramidal cells of the
like hippocampus and
the Purkinje cells
of the of the
cerebrum. So here's
like one example of a
Purkinje cell.
Again, to confirm the
diagnosis, you can do
either entry detection,
like using direct
immunofluorescence
microscopy, or you can do
RT-PCR from the samples.
But you need multiple,
multiple samples to
confirm the infection,
serums, CSF skin,
because sometimes the
virus may not be
present in one that you
don't want to end up
with the false negative.
The next few slides
are examples of
board style questions
that you may have
on the subject for
you to practice.
Of course, if you want
to know the answers,
look back at the
slides or talk to
your peers in your
group studies and figure
those out. But
those will be very
similar to what you'd
see both on boards and
on the exams. And as
you know me, you've
seen examples of
those before. Here's
just a summary
slide about what we
just talked about.
We basically, of
course, there's
always defined
different types of
central nervous system
illnesses but we
focus mainly on
viral infections of
central nervous system
predominantly acute
viral meningitis and
viral encephalitis.
We've talked extensively
about the epidemiology
of these two infections
and how to diagnose
them and then we
talked about the most
common type of viral
central nervous system
radiologies like ******
and enteroviruses
and Coxsackieviruses.